there's new evidence that the virus has
had a troubling racial impact an
Associated Press analysis of nearly
3,300 coronavirus patients who died
found 42 percent of them were
african-american blacks only make up
about 21% of the total population in
that study the White House says
Philadelphia could be a new hotspot
Errol Barnett asked city leaders what
they're doing to flatten the curve in
minority neighborhoods
Philadelphia's health commissioner
sounded the alarm bells Thursday as the
city's infections surpassed 5,000
sharing new data confirming
african-americans are most at risk there
are real socio-economic barriers when it
comes to messaging in places like this
in North Philadelphia roughly half the
people here don't have access to the
Internet and a majority of people in
this part of town live below the poverty
line and that's why some are resorting
to creative ways of getting the word out
latinum are vulnerable Rashidah Rashidah
nice town Community Development Center a
non-profit serving 70,000 low to middle
income residents in Philadelphia we're
calling them on a telephone directly the
new ways we're trying to reach out to
people are kind of you know we use them
anyway but social media on all platforms
including the ways that younger people
use it on on IG councilman Darrell Clark
says there are many reasons people of
color are bearing the brunt of kovat 19
we look at all of the structural issues
around all of these health care
inequalities all of these lower income
jobs it tends to impact individuals and
neighborhoods of color a lot more than
it does in other neighborhoods and Clark
says people of color tend to be on the
frontlines with jobs leaving them
exposed we have individuals that are
working in these jobs and retail and
supermarkets and stores around that are
still allowed to be open those people
have to deal with the public on a
consistent basis right they are more
likely to come in contact with somebody
that may be affected than other
people and we're also told
generalized mistrust in the government
from generations of feeling marginalized
maybe playing a role of why it's more
difficult to get these messages to
minority groups which is why you see
folks
excuse me like majeeda Rasheed using
phone banks to speak to the elderly she
says they're telling her they just want
to hear a trusted local friendly voice
and Tony they are afraid right now yeah
you can certainly understand that
Erol thank you very much